en el último vídeo demostramos que la
suma de todos los enteros positivos
hasta n se puede expresar como n por n 1
entre 2 y lo demostramos por inducción
ahora lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo
es mostrar que hay una demostración más
sencilla para ello pero que no es por
inducción solo para que veas que la
inducción no es la única forma de
demostrar este resultado ok entonces
vamos a empezar como teníamos en el
vídeo anterior definiendo nuestra
función sdn sdn era la suma de todos los
enteros positivos hasta entonces era uno
más 2 + 3 y así sucesivamente sumamos
hasta n de hecho bueno podemos sumar en
n 1 y luego sumamos hasta n ahora bien
si yo yo yo en realidad de esta suma la
puedo reescribir voy a reescribir sdn la
suma ahora empezando con n y terminando
en 1 es decir voy a poner n
+ n menos uno más en m2 y así voy
sumando hasta dos más uno ok
simplemente esta suma es exactamente la
misma de arriba pero reescrita ahora en
orden descendente
entonces fíjense qué es lo que pasa si
yo sumo estas dos formas pues en
realidad sólo tengo dos veces la suma de
todos los enteros hasta n verdad
ok ahora si yo sumo del lado derecho qué
es lo que ocurre qué es lo que ocurre
estos primeros dos términos voy a ir los
agrupando de esta forma me dan n1n1 muy
bien ahora qué pasa si yo sumo estos dos
términos en el menos 12
tengo 2
n 1 que no es otra cosa más que dos más
n 1 entonces dos menos uno es uno y si
le sumamos n me queda n 1 entonces estos
dos sumados me dan n más uno que pasa
ahora si yo sumo estos este par tengo en
m2 y le sumó 3 entonces eso simplemente
me da otra vez n 1
entonces si nos damos cuenta en realidad
estamos sumando muchísimos n n 1 por
ejemplo estos 2 otra vez tengo n menos
12 pues es n 1 y ahora tengo n 1 aquí
ny1 pues suma 2 me dan n1n1 entonces
tengo puros n 1 si si sumamos dos veces
o bueno si sumamos la sección a raro
pero si sumamos la suma consigo misma en
realidad tengo muchos en unos ahora la
pregunta es cuántos en unos tengo
cuántos de estos tengo y en realidad
tengo aquí
2 3 n 1 hasta en realidad tengo n veces
n menos 1 verdad entonces esto se repite
n veces muy bien entonces lo que tenemos
es que 2 veces nuestra suma va a ser
igual a n veces en realidad tengo n
veces n más o no verdad así lo puedo
expresar ahora si dividimos entre 2 de
ambos lados si dividimos entre 2 de
ambos lados lo que voy a tener es que
estos se cancelan y tengo que la suma de
los primeros en enteros va a ser igual a
n por n 1 sobre 2 y llegué justamente a
la fórmula que había llegado en el vídeo
anterior así que aquí hay una
demostración una prueba en donde no
tuvimos que usar inducción esto fue una
demostración puramente algebraica